Democratic presidential contender Bernie
Sanders is looking to build more
momentum in the upcoming Nevada caucus
and South Carolina primary his victory
in New Hampshire on Tuesday what's the
independent senator from Vermont in
second place in the delegate count with
21 former mayor Pete Budaj edge leads
with 23
senator Sanders joins us from Dulles
Virginia on his way to campaign in North
Carolina good morning senator thanks for
being with us my pleasure
congratulations on the victory in New
Hampshire but the results they're due
should still show a significant split in
the party between the moderates and the
left you're we as we mentioned upcoming
is the upcoming primary in South
Carolina and one of the two Democratic
congressman there just said we don't
want socialism how do you broaden your
constituency but look we are taking on
the entire establishment we're taking on
Wall Street and we're taking on the
greed and corruption of the
pharmaceutical industry and we're taking
on the insurance companies because we
believe that it's time that every
American and healthcare is a human right
which exists that every other major
country on earth so we're talking on the
political establishment the Republicans
and the Democrats but at the end of the
day the agenda that we have which says
that if you work 40 hours a week in
America you should not be living in
poverty raise that minimum wage to 15
bucks an hour make sure that all of our
kids have the opportunity to get a
higher education regardless of their
income that is the agenda that the
American people want the establishment
may not like it that's what the American
people want that's why we're gonna win
senator I'm curious you've got this
label stuck to you socialist you've got
something from your own party the
Democratic Party's saying they don't
want socialism in South Carolina
referring to you I know there's a
difference between democratic socialism
and socialism but why do you cling and
hold on to that label democratic
socialists win it seems to confuse
people and give your enemies and critics
an opportunity to bash you well let me
just tell you something in my view to a
significant degree we are living right
now under Donald Trump in a socialist
society the only difference is does the
government work for working people what
does it work for billionaires Donald
Trump before he became president was in
real
state he received 800 million dollars in
tax breaks and subsidies from the
government socialism for the rich the
cut the fossil fuel industry receives
tens of billions of dollars a year in
subsidies and tax breaks for the rich
yet senator is the label confusing
people and allowing your critics to hurt
you politically well I did win the
popular vote in Iowa I did win the
popular vote and when the primary in New
Hampshire I think we're gonna win in
Nevada I think we're gonna win in South
Carroll and that we have got to finally
stand up to the corporate elite and that
we have to have a mass political
movement of working people and
low-income people and young people to do
that so I'm not worried about labels we
will define ourselves not let other
people define us senator Sanders
speaking of those wins in Iowa and New
Hampshire
you actually trail in the polls a recent
Quinnipiac poll with black voters
compared to Bloomberg and Biden so how
do you plan to beat those candidates in
a more diverse State oh you just wait
and see I don't know what the recent
most recent poll has but we are doing
very very well with minority the men
already communities both
african-american and Latino and our
Coalition is gonna build around minority
communities build around young people
and create an unprecedented grassroots
movement look a lot of politicians go
from the top line now that's what
Bloomberg is about he's spending
hundreds of millions of dollars that's
fine we don't have hundreds of millions
dollars our movement is made up of
working people of young people and we're
gonna put that coalition together we are
gonna take on the establishment and I
believe we're gonna win senator the DNC
just changed the rules which could allow
mr. Bloomberg to appear in the next
debates do you think he should be on the
debate stage of course not that is what
that is what being a multi-billionaire
is about some very good friends of mine
who were competing in the Democratic
nomination people like Cory Booker of
New Jersey senator Julian Castro work
really really hard nobody changed the
rules to get them into the debate but I
guess if
worth 60 billion dollars you can change
the rules I think that is very very
unfortunate senator let's jump ahead to
the prospect of a Sanders administration
you've got these ideas if you're elected
how do you get them through a logjam in
the Senate because you rally the
American people the ideas that we are
talking about all the ideas that the
overwhelming majority of the American
people want and what I've said many many
times I will not only be
commander-in-chief as president I will
be organizer in chief and that means I
will go to Kentucky I will go to those
states that are struggling and say to
the people in those states you tell your
Senators whether or not you think health
care is a human right you tell your
Senators whether you think we should
raise the minimum wage to 15 bucks an
hour
tell your senators whether we take on
the corruption and greed of the
pharmaceutical industry which charges us
ten times more for the same medicine as
is charged in other countries we rally
the American people and finally maybe
just finally we'll have a Congress that
works for the American people not
wealthy campaign contributors
senator Sanders we thank you for your
time thank you very much